let's discuss the Hallmarks of cancer
experts all over the world has described
these six as Hallmarks of cancer cancer
cell would resist cell death they have
sustaining proliferative signaling they
evade growth factor suppressors they can
activate Invasion and metastasis
they enables replicative immortality
that means can divide infinitely and
they can induce angiogenesis
a mutation in protoncogene or in the
tumor suppressor Gene can lead to
eventually uncontrolled growth and that
is the cause of tumor formation and this
tumor is innervated with blood vessels
which Supply them nutrients and that is
known as angiogenesis
Sometimes some of these tumor cells can
dislodge and move through the
bloodstream and can populate in a
secondary location that is known as
metastasis
watch the full video to know more